welcome to this video i'm playing ex
back some relation to the firm former
german football or soccer player ok it's
got the Mexican flag though let's see
the Rubenstein and okay yeah maybe
transpose to sort of sort of the
sandwich it's not hey this is this is
possible now we transpose to the famous
set up from but Vinnie cam kappa Blanca
Oh Bishop to g4 really the thing is I
want to play this anyway f3 and yeah
night f1 seems to net me the the
complete bishop am not sure if I should
ok let's take the bishop am
hmm it seems it's not necessarily
playing Knight to Bishop to g6 no very
unnatural move in a way anyway how do i
am play that i always like this maneuver
look eat a 2 2 e 2 and eventually push
the center what he absolutely needs to
avoid now is see form okay may he
avoided that okay here i have two good
options actually taking with the e porn
is also not bad opening up my bishop but
ok i will take him keep the extra send
upon
the problem is really we get we get this
situation of two nights against two
bishops and this is normally bad news
father bad news for the for the Knights
this Bishop b2 and eventually form would
be nice I still expect him to at some
point Bishop g6 oh here we go okay and
maybe he can really double-double on
them on the EVO so that if all is very
tricky to play maybe
yeah it seems to be that I have problems
to play this you form this pressure on
d4 and here i cannot play easily bishop
and maybe i can do that actually Bishop
b2 and deform maybe i can still do it at
the moment I don't see why not with the
doubling on the e-file I have enough
enough pieces on e4 to maybe really make
this make this make this real eform
night see four maybe five so I can play
that
I also don't mind if he would get the a
3 porn or something it's not not really
important I hope yeah of course black
needs to get some sort of technical
counter play with the night and de
pronto otherwise my porn roller in the
center will be too much yeah something
like that you must do so just if I if
maybe here maybe if 5 push the pawn
until the night on g4 it's not really
having any any squares night peace a
queen bee 6 may be here intending to
take on you five yeah I don't know this
position is still very very very tricky
very tricky with 94 coming
night f2 that now yeah it's possible
that she has has good good play here
with with his nights I am not good it's
not really great here and Bishop e2
maybe yeah this is technically very
shaky I probably needed one or two more
preparation moves for your form I cannot
really evaluate this may be i'm falling
apart maybe I'm not okay this is more
looking like the falling apart variation
check yeah this is yeah very shaky I
don't have don't have any any great
coordination in my pieces
queena for maybe I'm and then I've been
in an awkward situation I can go here
though where's he going now to h4 I need
to get get my pieces on good good
squares where they are safely positioned
Bishop a to weather is a move the I play
that here this is strong time morning
both bishops are unprotected but okay if
so
yeah I want coordination my pieces are
not coordinated well
Bishop have Noah the bishops have no one
no save save posts at least his I'm
taking some time I've been to g5 and
then then rook a one I need to invade
f3 also maybe Oh nope I need to protect
this
black for fish and helping to even look
at the clock we are probably amber C I'm
the beep on the beep on my computer is
equal yeah maybe I have enough counter
play here with with this H porn push I
was thinking about that yeah this this
is stuff him the H porn gr very
difficult very difficult here here here
i'm actually winning but i didn't i
didn't finish him off Bishop c5 a strong
yeah this also looked good but I need to
I need to keep the Queen's anyen I only
here only here really realize that I
then I have trouble taking him the
computer just takes him but the the back
rank ah the back rank there is no there
is no meat or anything I mean this
computer is totally unimpressed he's he
the computer sees Bishop g1 I didn't I
can just take everything off yeah and
then and then just do when yeah okay if
I can just take a five I understand that
I'm that I'm in good shape because i'm
also always a tech f7 which is very
difficult to defend the only problem was
this but i didn't see that I always have
just Bishop g1 so this year is
completely pointless i can just go back
and then he's in big trouble yeah ok
that's pretty clearly winning what i was
trying to do is to get some stable
position for my pieces there are some
chances left our bishop t4 was good but
okay I don't have any time be sure q4
was good yeah I don't know it seems that
this still pretty much okay or better
for me but difficult really difficult to
play
um at the outset + d 4 right I can
prepare at the ambition it towards may
be better but ok computer it's not
really arguing with it you should see
three years winning ok why exactly are
because of this idea ok yeah this looks
nice it's always difficult ready to live
which is such a situation as a human you
really always think okay I need to get
the King out of there this is tricky but
there is no big threat or anything this
is the stuff that the computer will
point out very quickly but as a human
player hmm very tricky ok thanks for
watching